if any just to continue on with our  amazing regular segment of a swear word  in  each lord of the rings film um  we've got one here from nigel  and this isn't even uh  this isn't even in the film it's just  the title of the film right he suggested  lord of the  which i think is harsh i don't know if i  like that one  when mary and pepin this is from  sheamus seamus martin who says when mary  and pippin go into saruman's storeroom  one of them should loudly exclaim  holy [ __ ]  the same answer excuse me the same  answer here from mattia  spear stem i've probably got their name  wrong and also  beach  beachum x  frodo to gandalf keep your secrets then  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your host the baby you're my pearl